Chapter 1
A common myth about learning is that re-reading
is an effective study strategy – but it’s
not.
Re-reading gives students confidence that
they know something when they actually don’t,
a key example in which “Learning is Misunderstood.”
Callender & McDaniel (2009)
Karpicke et al. (2009)
View fullsize
Make It Stick - 1 - Gadd.jpg
Make it Stick - 1 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 2
In “To Learn, Retrieve,” the authors describe
retrieval practice research in authentic classrooms.
Experiments in a K-12 school district demonstrated
that retrieval practice raised students' grades
from a C+ to an A-, with benefits lasting
for an entire school year.
McDaniel et al. (2011)
Roediger et al. (2011)
View fullsize
Make It Stick - 2 - Gadd.jpg
Make it Stick - 2 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 3
For this recommendation, “Mix Up Your Practice,”
the authors present research on two robust
teaching strategies: spacing and interleaving.
Research demonstrates that simply spacing
out or rearranging concepts to be taught can
yield a large boost in learning.
Kornell (2009)
Taylor & Rohrer (2010)
View fullsize
Make It Stick - 3 - Gadd.jpg
Make it Stick - 3 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 4
In this chapter, the authors encourage readers
to “Embrace Difficulties” during learning.
One example is the myth of errorless learning.
Contrary to popular belief, making errors
during retrieval is a good thing for learning.
In one experiment, students made errors while
studying, which improved their learning, yet
they didn't recognize this benefit.
Huelser & Metcalfe (2012)
Kang et al. (2011)
View fullsize
Make It Stick - 4 - Gadd.jpg
Make it Stick - 4 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 5
Students need to “Avoid Illusions of Knowing.”
Students consistently predict higher test
performance following ineffective strategies
(e.g., re-reading) compared to more effective
strategies (e.g., retrieval practice).
Numerous studies reveal that students drop
flashcards too fast due to poor metacognition
and awareness of their own knowledge.
Karpicke (2009)
Kornell & Bjork (2008)
View fullsize
Make it Stick - 5 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 6
Now is the time to “Get Beyond Learning
Styles.”
There is no empirical evidence that teaching
students consistent with their “learning
style” will improve learning.
In contrast, methods supported by scientific
evidence – including retrieval – are robust
and reliable methods that improve student
learning in the classroom.
Pashler et al. (2009)
Willingham et al. (2015)
View fullsize
Make It Stick - 6 - Gadd.jpg
Make it Stick - 6 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 7
In this chapter, the authors reveal how to
“Increase Your Abilities.”
One method they highlight is a growth mindset,
or the belief that learning and intelligence
are malleable rather than fixed.
Growth mindset encourages students to focus
on learning and growing with increasing challenges,
rather than performance at one point in time.
This pays off in increased student learning
and persistence over time.
Dweck (2008)
Paunesku et al. (2015)
View fullsize
Make it Stick - 7 - Kemper.jpg
Chapter 8
In the final chapter, called “Make it Stick,”
the authors provide tips for teachers, students,
and trainers.
In collaboration with two of the authors from
Make it Stick, our Retrieval Practice Guide
highlights some of the tips included in the
book.
We encourage you to read Make it Stick for
more research and recommendations to transform
student learning.
Download our guides!